[Music]  seven months after outlining his plan in  Athens to rebuild Europe French  president Emmanuel macron comes to  Strasbourg to discuss the --use future  in 2013 1.6 billion tonnes of waste in  EU were not reused or recycled MEP is  vote on a new law to boost the recycling  of waste packaging to reach the climate  change goals fixed in the Paris  agreement Parliament is to adopt a  greenhouse gas regulations in land use  and forestry organic food production in  the EU is a rapidly developing sector  Parliament will vote on rules to prevent  fraud guarantee fair competition and  improve consumer confidence terrorist  groups can take advantage of gaps in the  financial system to fund their  operations MEP vote on how to strengthen  the fight against money laundering and  terrorist financing